independent a restaurant coalition when
we're asking before is we need a
restaurant stabilization bill you know
you can bail out airlines and banks and
in time of need and we're not looking
for a bailout but we're looking for for
just some runway to keep opening and
what's at stake here bill is small
independent restaurants employ 11
million people in this country and if
you factor in farmers and fishermen and
cheese makers and wine makers is
probably closer to 20 million people and
so we're simply asking the government if
you're gonna spend stimulus dollars and
you said this earlier in the interview
that our margins are slim all our
margins are slim because 95 cents for
every dollar we take in goes out the
door and so if you really want to
actually take stimulus dollars and put
it through a entity that will spend that
money we're not gonna buy back of our
stocks with this you know what I'm not
going to give you no executive bonuses
that money's going out the door into the
economies I think that's very reasonable
for an industry that involves 20 million
Americans to ask for a ballot and I
would also just say a conclusion I don't
know if people really understand how
much restaurants are vital to the
lifeblood of civilization civilizations
happen because of cities and cities
don't really exist on a cultural level
without restaurants people need to sit
together I mean we're not exactly a cafe
society Europe is more but we still do
need to sit and break bread and talk
with each other and when I hear about
fabled restaurants going out of business
you know swingers went out of business
or the first one here I know if you know
swingers it's a diner it's the movie
swingers John that I've rose great movie
it's where [ __ ] Tarantino wrote every
one of the script sitting at that diner
bar there and you know I just don't know
if people understand how much we are
losing cultural rise when restaurants go
out of business and you're right
restaurants have become a part of the
culture and these are the places that
we're gonna need to go to the film
normal one where's one when we get
through this on the other side of this
places that you're gonna celebrate
birthdays and anniversaries places where
you gonna go to actually hang out with
your friends grab a drink a bottle of
wine some great food and feel normal
again and this is what we need to get
back to and you know bill I'm hoping
that the silver lining here if there's a
silver lining
is that maybe we're gonna have a more
empathetic country you know for years
you know as you know I'm a high hunger
advocate
and right now going it to into : pre
Kovac there's about 60 I'm sorry 38
million Americans on food stamps or snap
right now the estimate centers increased
about 70 percent so we're looking at
another 25 million people so after this
what are we aspire to get back to 38
million no we can do better than that
and what I'm hoping is that the
demonization of people who need help say
I need to pull themselves up by the
bootstraps and they make poor decisions
and why are they having kids and all of
that that we've heard for blaming those
people the average American now who's
lost her job for no fault of their own
no falter on that now they're struggling
and they're the ones who are now lining
up for food to food pantries and they're
the ones who are filling out those those
applications for snack maybe now we'll
have a better and deeper empathy for
people who were from no fault of their
own born into poverty I had a bad break
in and they need to get out of it and
hopefully now we're gonna see a more
empathetic French from the other side of
this that's what I'm hoping for and you
know and also I'm hoping that we see
because of these comorbidities revolve
around food diabetes and obesity and
things like that
hopefully on the other side us will
understand that proper nutrition and
good food actually will keep people
healthier and keep people from dying
when the next time then it comes right
what I've been preaching every week here
it's what I've been trying to get across
beautifully said great to see you dine
with you in person soon
you